there is a heartbreaking deleted scene
from avengers end game featuring tony
stark and his daughter morgan
immediately after tony snaps with the
infinity gauntlet this scene would have
absolutely changed the way we think
about big mcu concepts and heightened
our appreciation for the sacrifice tony
chose to make but it was left out on the
cutting room floor welcome to stream in
the galaxy i'm rocket riley and a
certain deleted scene from avengers in
game would have changed everything we
know about the mcu's infinity saga this
scene begins immediately after tony says
i am iron man and with the infinity
stones snaps thanos and his forces away
after this snap tony enters the soul
world where he sees a grown-up version
of his daughter morgan similar to how
thanos entered the soul world and saw a
young version of his daughter gamora
upon entering the soul world tony is
confused wondering where he is then he
hears a young woman call out to him who
he doesn't recognize at first he asks if
he knows her and she says that they're
actually pretty close he then recognizes
her to be his daughter morgan she tells
him that his snap worked and that she
got to grow up to live a full life he
tells her that he thinks he may have
made a bad decision by snapping but
morgan tells him that she's proud of him
and of what he did lastly she says that
she's happy for the time they had
together and that she loves him to which
tony replies i love you three thousand
calling back to when morgan told tony
that she loves him 3000 before going to
bed which was likely one of the last
times she ever saw him if this scene had
been included in the final cut of
avengers end game then several core mcu
concepts would have been completely
changed along with a few character
related changes after the events of
avengers infinity war and end game we
are given the understanding that when
someone was sacrificed in order to get
the soul stone their soul was trapped in
a place called the soul world a pocket
dimension located inside the soul stone
that's why thanos saw a young version of
gamora in the soul world when he snapped
since she was the one who he sacrificed
on vormir to get the soul stone the idea
was that when anyone used the stones
their consciousness would be transferred
to the soul world to atone for their
actions just as thanos's consciousness
was transferred to the soul world where
he explained that it cost everything to
achieve his goal with this deleted scene
though this whole concept has changed in
the scene tony sees his daughter morgan
who had basically nothing to do with
thanos or any sacrifice on vormir if
this scene were to be included it might
have made more sense for tony to see
natasha romanov who sacrificed herself
on vormir so that clint barton could
live and bring the soul stone back they
could have talked about how they both
sacrificed everything for the ones they
love even though they were leaving
behind different things this could have
been a pretty touching scene which
likely would have made more sense to
audiences if a short explanation was
given as to why thanos sagamora or why
tony saw natasha in this surreal world
it could be plausible that rather than a
pocket dimension located inside the soul
stone though the soul world is simply a
manifestation of the individual's fears
or regrets that they have to face after
using the stones that would basically be
the only case where it would make sense
for tony to see morgan in the soul world
rather than natasha all the details
aside if this scene had been included it
would have just further emphasized the
huge sacrifice tony made in order to
save the world many people complained
that tony could have simply given the
stones to captain marvel or the hulk to
take out thanos forces but as doctor
strange said after looking at 14 605
potential outcomes it was the only way
if he had tried to give them to someone
else thanosaurus forces could have
stopped him somehow tony was destined to
make this sacrifice from the moment he
said i am iron man in the first iron man
film this deleted scene would have just
punched that idea home further showing
the full emotional weight tony must have
felt and leaving behind not just his
wife but his daughter too ultimately
though the scene wasn't included in the
final cut of the film because it didn't
resonate with audiences and test
screenings the producers opted to skip
over the scene since it confused some
audiences and it seemed to slow down the
emotional development between scenes at
this point in the movie which makes
sense because the next scene would have
been tony's death scene one which is
pretty heavy emotionally following that
we get a hologram of tony giving his
final will and testament tony's funeral
and steve rogers handing off the mantle
of captain america to sam wilson all of
which are hefty emotional scenes it
makes sense that the scene wouldn't be
included due to the high number of
emotional scenes near the end of the
film also the scene would have caused
tons of confusion since the actress
playing tony's daughter morgan is one we
had yet to see before not only would
audiences be confused that there was a
new actress on screen but it would have
been confusing why tony was seeing his
daughter at all if the deleted scene had
been included though then people would
have likely had much different theories
about the infinity stones and in
particular about the soul stone if you
want to hear about the craziest marvel
theory we've seen check out this video
also don't forget to subscribe and like
this video and from everyone here at
stream in the galaxy thanks for watching
you